bien bonjour à toutes et à tous et bonne
rentrée pour ceux qui qui reviennent
bienvenue donc pour ce ce point presse
des républicains avec Philippe Juvin
nous souhaitons commencer par une
question de grande gravité qui est lié à
la sécurité nationale de notre pays
puisque nous avons appris récemment que
deux journalistes du Monde se sont
procuré une note classée confidentielle
défense et que dans cette note et bien
ils ont eu la chronologie extrêmement
précise d'une action qui n'a pas eu lieu
mais qui aurait pu avoir lieu et qui
impliquait les services secrets français
il nous semble alors que nous sommes en
situation de guerre le gouvernement le
président de la République nous indique
que nous sommes en situation de guerre
que cela n'est pas normal pour dire les
choses de façon basse et nous nous
interrogeons de façon très claire sur la
façon dont ces journalistes se sont
procurés c'est not cette note nous
demandons au gouvernement et au
président de la République de faire
toute la lumière sur cette affaire nous
souhaitons savoir si éventuellement
d'autres notes ont pu être divulgué
et nous nous étonnons du lien qui
pourrait être fait entre 60 entretiens
qui ont été fait entre ces deux
journalistes et le président de la
République et la divulgation de cette
note nous interrogeons est-ce que le
Président de la République a divulgué
cette note est-ce que ces services ont
divulgué cette note il s'agit encore une
fois de sécurité nationale nous ne
pouvons pas dans la situation dans
laquelle est notre pays accepter que
cela puisse avoir lieu avec force nous
réclamons que ce grave problème trouve
aujourd'hui une
réponse deè élément avant de passer aux
questions
européennes nous avons fait notre
rentrée politique euh les républicains
avec un certain nombre de personnels ité
qui ont tenu leur meeting de rentrée
lors de ce weekend avec le campus des
jeunes républicains qui se tenu au
Touquet où le président Laurent vquier
est intervenu les primaires sont donc
bien lancé et nous en sommes satisfaits
le 9 septembre nous saurons qui sont les
candidats qui restent en list vous
connaissez bien évidemment les règles
qui s'applique pour pouvoir être
candidat
Infiné nous rappelons comme notre
président l' indiqué que aujourd'hui
nous souhaitons qu'un un code de bonne
conduite puisse se tenir et que nous
soyons clairement sur le registre des
idées et non pas sur le registre des
personnes et le parti comme leurvoqué
encore une fois l' dit sera garant de ce
fait que nous soyons clairement sur le
registre des idées et non pas sur le
registre des
attaques dernier point euh au niveau du
registre Inter
intérieur le Conseil d'État euh vous le
savez a rendu un un jugement rendant
illégal un arrêté d'interdiction du
burkini nous ne contestons pas cette
décision le Conseil d'État juge en
l'état du droit et en l'état du droit il
n'y a pas matière effectivement à en
dire davantage nous rappelons néanmoins
que en
1989 lors de l'affaire de Cray le
Conseil d'État avait déjà jugé en l'état
du droit en indiquant que les jeunes
filles qui souhaitaient venir voiler à
l'école pouvaient le faire et à cette
époque là il a été considéré qu'une loi
devait être prise afin que le principe
supérieur pour nous qui est celui de la
la laïcité et autre principe supérieur
qui est celui de l'égalité hommes-femme
et bien puisse trouver sa justification
et sa place dans la loi il nous semble
donc qu'il sera nécessaire
de d'adopter une loi interdisant ce
vêtement qui avant tout est euh l'image
d'un islam radical politisé militant
provocquant qu'il faudra adopter une loi
pour l'interdire non pas contre mais
tout simplement pour pour rappeler nos
us et nos coutumes pour rappeler
l'égalité hommes-femme qui évidemment
est absolument intangible au sein de la
République et pour faire en sorte et
bien que chacun euh puisse
dans notre République aller et agir sans
qu'il y ait de trouble à l'ordre publici
on a vu à Cisco malheureusement que cela
n'avait pas été le cas les républicains
soutiennent bien évidemment les maires
qui ont pris ces arrêtés et les
républicains demande instamment à Manuel
Vals le Premier ministre qui lui-même a
indiqué qu'il soutenait les maires qui
ont pris ses arrêtés et bien de prendre
ses responsabilité de mettre en
adéquation sa parole et ses actes il a à
plusieurs reprises indiqué qu'il
soutenait les maires nous demandons à
Monsieur Vals de faire en sorte que ce
soutien ne soit pas qu'un soutien de
parole mais devienne un soutien
d'acte la République a besoin d'acte
elle n'a pas besoin de parole donc
monsieur Vals prenez une initiative pour
faire en sorte que les maires ne se
retrouvent pas seuls pour faire en sorte
qu'il y ait une unité sur le territoire
de la France pour faire en sorte et bien
que le gouvernement
gouverne nous allons passer maintenant
aux questions européenne Philippe merci
Valérie donc il y a trois points que je
voudrais aborder avec vous le premier
point concerne la Turquie l'accord entre
l'Union et la Turquie qui a beaucoup
évolué durant l'été le second point le
sommet européen qui aura lieu le 16
septembre à Bratislava et le 3ème point
la crise qui est une très grande source
d'inquiétude pour les républicains la
crise du lait alors sur la Turquie vous
savez qu'il y avait cet accord entre
l'Union européenne et la Turquie accord
que nous avions dénoncé qui était selon
nous un accord de DUP où nous avions
cédé au
chantage de la Turquie accord pour la
libéralisation des visas libéralisation
des visas qui doit qui doit en fonction
et en vertu de cet accord se dérouler
dans 2 mois nous considérons nous le
disions déjà dès le début que toutes les
conditions ne seraient pas à la fin
respecté pour que ces visas soient
libéralisés or nous avons nous avons pu
assister durant le mois d'août à une
offensive très très forte des Turcs qui
ont menacé les Européens d'ouvrir les
vannes c'est le l'expression très peu
glorieuse des Turcs quand il parle des
des des réfugiés politiques et des des
réfugiés de guerre de la Syrie et d'Irak
et les Turques en réalité ont montré
leur vrai visage durant le mois d'août
en menaçant quasiment tous les de jours
les pays européens d'une déferland
d'immigration si on ne bradait pas nos
visas il est évidemment hors de question
pour les républicains que la France se
prête à un tel jeu nous avons dénoncé
cet accord nous continuons à le dénoncer
et si demain nous revenons aux affairire
nous aurons un accord avec les Turcs je
le rappelle forcément l'Europe doit
travailler avec la Turquie qui est un
grand pays et qui est un élément de
stabilité de la région mais jamais nous
n'accepterons son entrée dans l'Union
d'ailleurs elle s'en éloigne à grands
pas cont tenu de ce qui se passe depuis
la tentative de coup d'état euh vous
pouvez voir les emprisonnements
permanent en particulier des
journalistes qui sont absolument
ahurissants dans un monde moderne on
parle de rétablissement de la peine de
mort en Turquie bref tous éléments qui
devraient terminer de convaincre tous
ceux qui pensaient que la Turquie
pouvait entrer dans l'Union qu'elle n'a
vraiment pas sa place toutefois avec les
Turcs nous obtiendrons un accord mais ce
sera un accord gagnant gagnant il ne
sera pas question que les européens
soient les dindons de la farce euh de de
de cet accord le deuxème point c'est la
question du sommet européen qui aura
lieu le 16 septembre à Bratislava en
fait ce ce sommet peut se résumer à un
score le score c'est Allemagne 13 France
0 qu'est-ce que c'est Allemagne 13
France 0 et bien pour préparer ce sommet
Madame Merkel a rendu visite à 13 États
de l'Union depuis 3 semaines pour faire
avancer cette théories en particulier
sur le brexit et pendant ce temps-là
François Hollande n'a pas fait une seule
visite officielle dans aucun des états
de l'union et la le vrai sujet est le
suivant c'est que désormais ces sommets
européens sont des sommets allemands
avec les les états de l'union et la
France n'y a pas sa place pourquoi il
n'y a pas sa place non pas parce que
l'Allemagne ne le souhaite pas mais
parce que la France ne prend plus cette
place et il paraît absolument incroyable
que François Hollande continue à aller
visiter son département d'origine comme
on l'a appris durant durant les vacances
à travers des confidence de quelques-uns
de vos vos confrères qui le suivent dans
ces dans ces pérégrinations en
permanence mais n'a pas le temps de
mettre les pieds chez nos voisins qui
sont pour ceux avec lesquels il faut
évidemment discuter la France encore une
fois est à zéro et l'Allemagne à 13 le
sommet de Bratislava a étéit précédé
d'un autre sommet un sommet
franco-allemand du 22 août et là aussi
c'est une preuve supplémentaire de notre
disparition puisque pour la première
fois mesdames et messieurs
le sommet franco-allemand était un
sommet franco-allemand- italien Madame
Merkel le 22 août
a convoqué même si c'était en Italie en
réalité c'est elle qui était la
puissance invitante sur un navire de
guerre au mouillage ce qui est en dilant
sur dilon sur la la dynamisme
actuellement du couple franco-allemand
et elle a invité Mattheo renzy à la
discussion qu'elle devait avoir lieu
initialement en tête attaque avec
François Hollande pour préparer le
sommet de Bratislava et d'ailleurs faut
il faut noter que dans les attendus de
la conférence Madame Merkel a félicité
monsieur renzy de ses réformes en
particulier en particulier de ce qu'on a
appelé le job Act nous en avions parlé
ici évidemment pas un mot sur la loi
Macron ou sur aucune loi française donc
perte en permanence de vitesse de la
France dans le coupe franco-allemand
disparition du coupe franco-allemand ce
sera évidemment une de nos priorités
revenu aux affaires c'est réanimer ce
coupe franco-allemand faire en sorte que
enfin la France soit de nouveau entendue
et ça un effet sur le troisème point que
je voulais aborder c'est la question
laitière qui est d'une très grande
gravité puisque nous sommes en train
tout simplement et tout malheureusement
euh d'assister à la disparition de la
filière laitière française un grand pays
comme le nôtre ne peut pas ne pas avoir
de filières
laitières et pourquoi nous nous nous
voyons cette filière laitière
disparaître parce que le prix du le le
prix du lait éta en juillet 2014 de 363
€ pour 1000 l désormais il est acheté à
280 € pour 1000 l donc on est passé de
363 à 280 € en en 2 ans avec des coûts
de production qui ne cessent d'augmenter
et c'est un des deux du problème les
coûts de production sont de l'ordre de
350 € par 1000 litre donc aujourd'hui
les producteurs français sont absolument
asphyxié par des prix qui baissent et
des coûts de production qui montent
revenu aux affaires il est clair que
d'abord nous baisserons d' manière
massive les charges dès l'été prochain
pour les PME les PMI et particulièrement
les agriculteurs sinon il n'y aura plus
de filière laitière française nous
sommes dans l'urgence nous
réorganiserons et nous restructurerons
des des filières qui aujourd'hui sont
moribondes entre les producteurs les
transformateurs les distributeurs c'est
ce que demande les jeunes agriculteurs
en particulier nous pensons que c'est
une très bonne idée c'est une des
solutions restructurer ces filièr qui
ont disparu ce qui signifie qu'il faut
que nous obtenions une modification du
droit européen de la concurrence qui
aujourd'hui empêche d'aller jusqu'au
bout et comment comment obtenir une
modification du droit européen de la
concurrence en particulier permettant
aux producteurs de faire des stockages à
plusieurs
bref de faire un certain nombre de
pratiques qui ne sont pas toutes
autorisées et bien nous ne pourrons
modifier le droit à la concurrence que
si nous pesons en Europe c'est toujours
pareil on en revient toujours à ce débat
l'idée c'est pas de peser en Europe pour
peser en Europe c'est de peser en Europe
pour peser sur la vie quotidienne des
Français enfin je rappelle que Stéphane
Lefol en 2015 nous l'avions dénoncé ici
a manqué un Conseil européen sur deux en
matière agricole un sur deux et quand
vous n'êtes pas présent au conseil
agricole tout simplement vous ne pouvez
pas techniquement défendre les intérêts
des agriculteurs français alors je ne
sais pas si son score s'est amélioré
depuis 2016 mais en général à la fin
d'année scolaire les mauvais élèves
n'ont pas tendance à améliorer leurs
notes et donc je pense que Monsieur le
fa n'a pas amélioré sa sa mauvaise note
voilà ces trois sujets d'ordre européen